orcas have a language of their own
they communicate through touch movement
and most importantly
sound and it's marine scientist elene
hamron's job to eavesdrop on them
she's an acoustic researcher studying
the sounds marine mammals like whales
and dolphins
use to communicate she's captured
hundreds of hours of orca recordings
like the one you're hearing whales are
using
sound as their primary sense unlike
humans that are using their vision
so it's very important for whales to be
able to communicate to each other
to find mates to search for prey
also to navigate the area
this summer she's listening to the orcas
of norway's lefoutin archipelago
beloved by the creatures for its healthy
populations of herring and other fish to
feed on
but an invisible problem is increasingly
alarming experts
noise pollution from whale watching
cruises oil exploration
and other human activity
elene has set out to study how it
affects the whales
and she hopes to use her findings to
help make lefutin a marine protected
area
limiting unwelcome noise and blocking
oil drilling
she works for ocean sounds a non-profit
that advocates for marine ecosystem
conservation and has been tracking orcas
here in the futin
since 2003. on a typical day
aline her husband bjorn their dog bailey
and a team of researchers drive around
the islands in an inflatable boat
looking for action when they spot whales
they slowly approach then turn off the
engine to minimize noise
they use an underwater microphone called
a hydrophone to record vocalizations
during socializing they're producing a
variety of vocalizations
it can be whistles calls buzzes clicks
um same with when they're feeding
they're a little bit more
quiet when they're traveling
so we'll be able to go and record them
uh when we have the right moment
they also photograph the orcas to keep
track of the family groups
the scientists assign each of them a
number and add them to a catalog
we will be able to use this method
to track them over time it's a very
non-invasive and inexpensive way
of doing the research bjorn operates a
drone that films whales from above
over time they match the orca's sounds
with behaviors
gradually learning their complex
language
each pod speaks its own dialect so
tracking them is essential for
understanding the communication
the large population of whales also
attracts thousands of people looking for
boat tours every year
these ships full of whale lovers can
actually be quite disturbing to ocean
life
we've had issues of boats zooming
through
pods sometimes even between the mother
and calf it's also
quite loud on the hydrophone
even loud enough that you want to turn
the volume down but the whales are not
able to
go in and modify um how loud the boats
are
and i don't think people are aware of
this issue
when a boat drives too close to orcas it
can overpower their calls
it could mask the vocalizations that
they can't be able to communicate with
each other nearby
or find a mate and it can scare away the
fish orcas feed on
they spend quite a lot of time rounding
up the herring to feed and then
a boat could come way too close and
now disperse the fish the looming threat
of oil drilling also poses a problem
in 2019 the norwegian government reached
a deal to block drilling in lefutin for
now
but every seat in the parliament is up
for election in september 2021
which could put the area at risk again
and even without permission to drill
companies can still use blasts of
compressed air to map where oil lies
beneath the ocean floor
these seismic surveys can be louder to
marine life than fireworks from three
feet away
researchers aren't sure how these sounds
affect ocean mammals health
but studies have found that a single
airgun blast can be heard underwater for
months
all this combined with the occasional
military exercises in the area
creates an underwater cacophony that
interrupts whale communications
they're vocalizing already at the
surface so we'll deploy the hydrophone
just boat noise now they've stopped
calling
because orcas are instinctively
collaborative communication
is central to everything they do
disoriented whales may also swim out of
their usual living area
with the whales wanting to be away from
all the boat noise and needing a bit
more space
sometimes they're hugged a bit on the
coastline too close to the rocks
elene says this may explain why the
spring of 2020
saw more whales stranded on the coasts
than any previous season
it could be due to noise pollution and
acoustic trauma
if we were able to be here within
the first 48 hours of when the whale's
stranded
and to actually look into the
head and see if there's any damage
within the ear
canal areas the strandings could also
have been caused by a harmful algae
bloom
or a virus that affected several species
but unless elene and the team can
examine a stranded whale
shortly after its death they can't
gather much information
it actually wasn't reported in time to
really see
why it had died we unfortunately cannot
take a blubber sample
since it's decayed too much usually at
this point we take a
tooth or we take a bone sample
and there were no teeth in the jaw
but we do have a sample of one of the
vertebrae that we've taken
elene collected samples from other
stranded whales including a pilot whale
during this research mission
these samples of blubber and bone can
tell researchers about an animal's
genetics
diet and more
ultimately elene's findings support
ocean sounds efforts to educate the
public about protecting the mammals
our focus isn't only on research but
we're also focused on conservation
and outreach and education ocean sounds
has a set of guidelines for whale
watching boats that they're lobbying to
turn into norwegian law
they include requiring boats to slow
down shift into neutral
and then turn off the engine while
approaching whales and
maintaining a minimum distance of 50
meters at all times
the goal is to regulate noise levels in
the region while still allowing whale
watching and fishing to operate
and making lefoutin a marine protected
area would ban oil exploration and
drilling in the area
until that happens ocean sounds is
selling recordings of whale
communications online
as a way to raise awareness and fund
their operations
we're trying to be able to not only
study the
vocalizations and behavior but also to
bring the whales to the people giving a
voice to the whales
[Music]
so
you